we're continuing our interviews with all
sorts of different 2022 candidates and
today i'm going to be speaking with adam
steen who's a self-described america
first candidate endorsed by the former
president donald trump currently running
a write-in campaign
in the 63rd district for the wisconsin
state assembly adam i really appreciate
your time today
thanks for having me david i appreciate
it so indulge me i know this we may get
through this first question in one word
and then we can move on but it's just a
good gut check who's the current
president of the united states
donald trump
oh the current president is trump
no right right now it's joe biden sir
okay did he legitimately win do you
think does his presidency reflect the
will of the voters
i believe especially here in the state
of wisconsin we have some major
questions that we'd like to ask and we
have not been able to bring those before
a judge here in the state of wisconsin
who is preventing you from doing that
uh right now the only person that we can
find is uh my opponent robin boss
he has said multiple times that he is
going to do a full forensic cyber audit
when he got off the plane with the
president back august of last year and
he has done absolutely nothing of the
sort in order to find out really what
people want to know david they want to
know that their ballot counts their vote
is actually counted that's all they want
to know and what reason do we have right
now to question the results in which joe
biden won that state by 20 000 votes
what specifically do we have
uh in wisconsin let's go let's go
wisconsin so we have uh the supreme
court
announcing their ruling uh back about a
month and a half ago
that the ballot drop boxes are
and were
illegal there's two methods of
delivering your ballot in the state of
wisconsin constitution by statute you
can deliver it in the mail
or you can deliver it in person to the
clerk
the wisconsin election commission
decided to add a third option which is a
ballot drop box which is not clearly
defined in the statute
so
when the supreme court ruled they said
those drop boxes are and were illegal so
there were about 250 000 votes cast but
adam hold on a second hold on i know i
know you're too too good to do this to
us you know that if you read that
decision
what they found was that there were some
locations that were not accessible to
individuals with mobility issues and
they did they said nothing substantive
about
fraud related to the final count or
anything of the sort no no no no i was
simply giving you the reasoning you're
exactly right i would not mean to admit
that okay fair fair very correct david
very very correct
the amount of ballots that were cast by
that method
in lieu of the fact that it doesn't
follow the method to deliver the ballot
by the constitution yeah would would in
my case bring to question the fact that
those ballots whether legal or not were
cast in an unlawful manner you're
exactly right okay and do you also admit
that while it is totally within your
right to extrapolate whatever you want
based on that decision
the justices who who wrote the
descending opinion say
when people say the types of things
you're saying you're fanning political
flames in a way that is not good you're
making people think you're talking about
fraudulent results when all they said
was some of these weren't accessible to
people with disabilities that's all they
said
so what what they said if you read the
the final decision is that
they they're the method of delivery is
two sir right
so there's two methods of delivering the
statute
yes the wisconsin commission
introduced a third without going through
this the legislature
so that to me is an extremely scary
position to be in
the supreme court said that those those
boxes that were used
were not under the method of which
delivery was described in the
constitution so you are correct i'm not
trying to say that the supreme court
said the elections are valid none of
that good they just said they should
have all been uh accessible to
individuals with disabilities yep so
okay
the next thing that i'd like to point
out is we had uh justice gableman's 139
page report
and i would really like for that report
to be put before a judge and i would
like the judicial system to actually
make a ruling on the findings of that
report okay so
the wisconsin election commission
decided to remove special voting
deputies right
they said they were not necessary in
2020
and i believe
from the bottom of my heart my
great-grandmother died at 102 at our
house that they were that
that they were removed
and we had people that were executing
the elections and collecting ballots
that were not under the constitution
they were not followed okay so you've re
you've raised a couple of concerns
that's that's fair and but you're also
conceding that uh on that first one it's
really about disability rights let me
ask you this
what is a forensic election audit
because and the reason i ask is
everybody i ask has a different
explanation and when i point to audits
that have that have been done folks will
invariably say that's not really the
type of audit i'm talking about
um got it that's a very fair question
because you're exactly right david let's
go across the country right you look at
arizona yeah
look at georgia
even here in wisconsin the
the audit that that we'd like to find
out is what what happens to your ballot
when it goes through the machine i'm not
telling you the machines are fraudulent
i can't tell you that david you can't
tell me that okay i certainly can't tell
you the machines are fraudulent because
i have no reason to believe that yeah
and and i can't either right so good
can i can i maybe reframe this
discussion a little bit so
you can reframe it but i would love an
answer to what you mean by a forensic
election i apologize
so a friend that caught it is when when
your ballot gets cast right yes the
process by which your ballot is cast
once that ballot goes into whether it's
scan through a machine goes into a box
in a county courthouse gets counted yes
and the total results are finished i
believe that process
should be clear to the public so a
forensic audit to me is understanding
every step of that process without
equivocation okay now let me see if i
understand it and you tell me the
elements that are missing right because
i voted with these types of machines
before
um
i have a ballot
there's two options i have a ballot
i take my felt sharpie and i sort of
like connect two little black things and
make it a step a fixed line
i feed it in through a machine
presumably the machine identifies which
line i drew and credits that candidate
with a vote and then my ballot goes into
a pile and then later you could go back
in and count up the pieces of paper with
the lines and compare it to the results
from the machine is that a fair process
that that process yeah is the part of
the audit okay exactly right yes okay
and what else is there
well for for me
in wisconsin
we we have a process called early
absentee voting okay
and that's 47 days that starts september
22nd for the general election yep
in my opinion
based on the the i'd say the evidence if
you will that has never been presented
before court
that
we have men and women
here in wisconsin there's a there was a
case yesterday that they heard the doj
brought against a man by the name of
harry weight
hairy weight ex requested a ballot an
absentee ballot
for five people
with their birth date and their first
and last name that's the only thing you
need to request their ballot if they
voted absentee in the past there's no id
required
because they've already submitted a
request for an absentee ballot
the problem that i have is let's say
that what you and i just described as
perfectly flawless yeah right
i mean i'll concede that let's say it's
perfectly flawless
if you and i would like to request
ballots from an individual who has voted
one out of the last 15 election cycles
and we submit it be it an absentee
ballot in a mailbox sure
there is no way for you and i
based on the process you just defined
to confirm or deny whether or not that
ballot was cast by that individual so a
few things on that because i've heard
and read about this many many times
before that there's a few different
things number one is even if what what
you're saying is true in theory someone
could do that i could find someone who
hasn't voted in a really long time i'm
admitting you're right i could i could
try to figure out who hasn't voted in a
really long time
request a ballot in their name and then
fill it out and send it in fine
in order for us to be able to say it's
worth
x y or z audit investigation whatever i
would want to number one have evidence
that that happened in numbers that could
have swayed the results
and in order to believe that i would
have to have reason to think that one
side rather than the other
was disproportionately doing it because
even if i grant that what you're saying
could be done and was done
if it was done equally by republicans
and democrats it doesn't actually change
the outcome does it does my math check
out at least adam in other words if ten
thousand republicans do that and ten
thousand democrats do that with these
people who haven't voted in a while
biden still wins by twenty thousand
votes right the math checks out at least
oh
is he was that question too tough i
can't believe that was where why he left
adam where are you
oh my
i think he bailed because of that
question
what on earth
adam don't tell me that question was too
difficult
adam you're back
we were on hold yeah you put i thought
you bailed because that you didn't like
the question
no sir okay so my question was i'm glad
you're back my question was
if ten thousand democrats and ten
thousand republicans do the thing you
described it doesn't change the margin
of victory so the question i have is
what evidence do we have that what you
just described as possible was not only
done but was done by so many more
democrats than republicans that it would
change the outcome in wisconsin
i i would like to contend that your your
premise of your question is wrong okay i
will argue with your question tell me
how it's wrong
well so um my grandfather was in 82nd
airborne division we have men and women
who have died for this country so that
we can have the right to vote yes i i
personally believe that if if you use
the line of questioning that you've so
chosen that if both sides do it it's
okay that's not the that's not what i
said though okay
so it's a two-part question first
what evidence do we have that this was
done in large numbers at all because
that's been investigated in wisconsin
and part two is if it was done in large
numbers was it done disproportionately
by one side
so i would love absolutely love to hear
uh the first of all the premise of the
investigation that happened because this
is the perfect crime david okay for
you'd say that someone voted absentee
and their ballot was determined that
they actually did vote absentee and it
was found that they really didn't vote
because that would take a canvas when i
say a full friendship got it that would
take a canvas of the people that
actually elect were elected or voted in
this election so you're saying go door
knocking all the people who supposedly
voted and say did you really vote
well no no i'm asking your question you
you said that that was uh investigated
please tell me how was that investigated
because that's the only method i know
to verify what you just said well you do
it with a sample it was in vet you i
mean so again if the standard is
you want to
look up every absentee vote and then go
and check with the person did you vote
it could be done
it would require an insane amount of
resources in when we when we talk about
science when we talk about mathematical
significance
you can take a sample of those and
investigate them and when we do that
when we take a representative sample we
find
uh a combination of things you know
usually a few people who were alive when
they sent in their absentee ballot and
died by election day they didn't do
anything wrong this sometimes people die
you find examples of like junior senior
confusion where that yes a junior voted
as their dead father but the dead father
didn't vote so it doesn't it's still
just one vote it was just counted for
the wrong you you get to this point
where there's really nothing there when
you test a representative sample so
again for me to say
let's check everyone i would want to
have a sample that raises concerns and
that that hasn't happened when it's been
looked at in wisconsin
so so just to be clear um i
i did not know and you're you're telling
me that we did actually sample a county
because we did canvassing here in
wisconsin in racine county yeah
we found 400 people
voting
from a single-family household okay in
the 2020 election so if if you have
different evidence let's talk about that
but right right now i i would love love
to do some digging but i'm not gonna sit
and argue with fair fair okay i think
i've raised enough questions for you to
understand the origins of my skepticism
and you've pointed out what you want so
i think we can we can move on but you
have questions that you don't feel have
been answered just just one more thing
sir seriously with with regards to our
election um
to me the issue is really
can be solved in eight words it's simple
i i would like our election process to
be done in person
on paper
and count
one day and that would apply to donald
trump as well right because he voted
earlier months early by mail he wouldn't
be able to do that
every person except the military and our
elderly that are unable to get out and
vote because to me the men and women of
this country that have given their lives
so that you and i can have the freedom
to even have this conversation right
vote they died and gave their life so
that we could take the responsibility
that we have to make sure we go vote in
my election process right in just my
little district yep less than ten
percent voted
in the primaries yeah that's depressing
and that's common and sadly low voter
engagement i want more voter engagement
it is but but i guess to me the solution
is
i would like transparency a lot of the
questions that you and i are discussing
our system has been set up so that you
and i can't come to a conclusion
we can't come to a realistic idea that
we know that our vote was counted and
cast clearly and no one
adam listen i i gotta i want to get some
some other topics one of the things i
found super interesting was at one point
you wrote you would outlaw
contraceptives if you were given that
opportunity do i have that right and why
would you do that
well conveniently enough
you don't have it correct okay the new
york post i believe it was
um
was that where the this i don't have the
source in front of me i read a bunch of
stuff before i interview him yeah
i i did not write that um they asked me
what i believed personally yeah
and i said very clearly that i believe
that life begins a conception
where body is your choice
and you make a decision
before conception happens okay you and i
are adults we know how children are come
to this world
and if you make a choice there's a
consequence for that choice i personally
believe
that stopping the natural progression of
life which you again made a decision
in order to engage in sexual activity
as a person as an individual
that is something that i believe is
wrong to stop life as a as a
representative i'm not going to put the
lid back on pandora's box okay so you
wouldn't move to ban contraception but
you're against it you in other words you
believe even a condom is stopping the
process of life
personally yeah i'm talking about you
personally i know it's just you
personally
well there's a difference between policy
and personality yeah so personally yes i
believe that you are actually just
making a decision to engage in an
activity and you want to remove the
consequence and this applies not just to
uh oral contraceptives and plan b but
you're saying even a condom is
interfering with is it is it god's will
that you find is it religiously based or
where are you coming up with this
uh no i i'm saying you're trying to
remove the consequence for your decision
you want to enjoy an activity that you
have a physical pleasure yeah and you
removing the consequence that is
wouldn't that apply also to for example
wearing a seat belt in a car where the
natural consequence of driving fast
might be that you get hurt in an
accident and the seat belt is
artificially keeping you uh safe i mean
it's sort of a weird argument isn't it
it's a weird argument safe uh safety and
saving a life uh versus ending a life to
me is a an interesting but you consider
wearing a condom to be ending a life
well you're preventing a life right so
why
it's deferring a consequence that's what
i'm saying wow that's interesting that's
i've never i've honestly
i've heard right-wingers say
insurance shouldn't cover some of these
things but i've never heard anyone say
that condoms are just straight up wrong
that's so you're saying that view it's
not based on your religious beliefs
no i i believe that like david if think
about life if life doesn't begin at
conception if you don't defend life at
all stages yeah whether it be or end at
what what part
at what point does life have value well
with if you're using a condom there's
been no conception right you're going
even earlier
what happens at the end of life sir if
you're telling me that we'd like to have
um no consequences for any decision that
you make that's what you're telling me
that we would like to have plan b well i
decided to have sex right that's how
that's how conception happens
i would like to defer that consequence
i'm not going to say that government's
going to legislate morality they can't
okay
that as a legislator
wow that
this is mind-blowing adam i've never
heard this from anyone i mean you may be
in some way the most
uh socially conservative person no
condoms that and and you so how old were
you when you came to this view this
anti-condom view
when you say anti-condom it kind of
makes it kind of sound funny well it is
very funny i think i mean it's it's very
you're saying we have to defend all life
and like are you is masturbation wrong
can i ask that
is masturbation wrong right because then
you're talking about millions of
potential lives that are no never going
to get a chance
as as an individual yeah all as an
individual well
i i have been taught and i have come to
the conclusion in my life yeah that
i i believe that you are enjoying
um an activity that's
there's nothing wrong with it but at the
end of the day you you are actually like
you said you are snuffing out life but i
have not
probation is
is illegal sir wow
adam we are treading incredible new
ground here i have to say this is good
this is going to be i can't think of a
more interesting note on which we would
end than that
um but this is really giving me a lot of
uh a lot to think about i think for lack
of a better term
um the election is in november adam
steen is running to represent district
63 in the wisconsin state assembly he
has been endorsed by donald trump we
don't know whether donald trump is on
the same page on some of the condom
stuff i think it would be interesting to
to talk to him about that but adam i
appreciate so much your time today and
you laying out some of your views
thanks david i appreciate it